This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to another
fabulous Friday which is actually
pharmacist Friday here on Daily with Doc
and we have the amazing pharmacist Ben
Fuches with us today. My name is Becca
Dukes. I'm a certified holistic
certified holistic health coach, a
certified naturopathic practitioner, the
producer and host of the Daily with Doc
and Beega Show. and I am so grateful you
have chosen to spend part of your day
with us. So today's topic begins with a
question that some people may be very
uncomfortable with, but we hear it a
lot. Why do you think you can't take
your nutrients with your medications?
So, it's fascinating when you really
think about it because
every cell needs nutrition,
you take it away,
I'm going to let pharmacist Ben talk
more about that. Well, just because he
loves this so much, this program is for
educational purposes only and is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician, nor is it meant to
treat, diagnose, or cure any disease.
But folks, you are empowered. So, grab a
hold of your empowerment. And if you
were invited to this program by somebody
specific, make sure that you get back
with them because they're going to be
your number one point of contact. If you
found this on your own,
I have a team ready to take your call at
8559493377.
This is a team of certified holistic
health coaches who have been trained in
the philosophies of Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik
and pharmacist Ben Fuches and making
sure that your body is getting the
foundation
and addressing the root, not the fruit.
So, pharmacist Ben Fuches, thank you so
much for joining us today. And you know,
I was really excited when you chose this
topic because I get it all the time.
Well,
how's it going to interfere with my
medication? Or do I still have to take
my medication? Or should I stop taking
my vitamins while I take my medication?
Should I take them, you know, two hours
apart? What's the deal with this,
Pharmacist Ben?
>> Yeah. So, you kind of alluded to it
earlier. Nutrients are things that the
body needs, specifically cells need to
function.
Mhm.
>> Drugs are not in that category. Drugs
make things happen that the body doesn't
want to do. Nutrients facilitate the
movement down a pathway. Drugs explode
the uh the mountain side to create a
pathway.
You follow what I'm saying? Drugs are
not it's they're completely different
animals, apples and oranges. However, we
are somewhat complicit, me and you, and
and people who are who are um promoting
nutritional supplements when we say
things like EFAs will thin your blood or
or vitamin K will clot your blood or um
selenium will um make your heart work
better. You know, we use these kinds of
careless descriptors when we talk about
nutrition. EFAs don't thin your blood.
EFAs
make it easier for your body to thin
your blood if it wants to do so,
but they're not going to compel
your body to thin your blood to thin. A
drug will compel
your body to your blood to thin even if
it doesn't want to thin.
When your blood is clotted and thick and
sticky after you have if you have atrial
fibrillation or you have a heart
congestive heart failure or something
like that the clotting of the blood is a
function of the lack of movement of the
circulatory system.
So when you take an essential fatty acid
that will improve the um that will
improve the movement the fluidity of the
blood but it's not going to make the
blood thin. It's going to improve its
fluidity if that's what the body wants
to do. So it's the difference between a
poison and a helper. And when I say a
drug is a poison,
I'm not being poetic.
I'm not being rhetorical. I'm being
literal.
A drug is a literal poison.
Now the the the philosophy
of poisoning the body to get better is a
discussion that you have to have
philosophically. Do you believe that?
And if you're part of the medical model
and the medical model it we're all
programmed and conditioned and
hypnotized and entranced by the medical
model, vast majority of us are
then you'll say yes poisoning the body
to make it better is a very functional
effective strategy to get healthy. I
don't happen to believe that unless and
and you know a lot of us here on this
call don't believe that. Your doctor
believes that because that's part of
what he studies. Not because he's dumb,
not because he's mean, not because he's
Satan incarnate. It's because that's how
he's trained there. That's what they
study. So guess what?
If you go to a doctor, you're going to
be doctorred.
You don't go to a doctor if you want to
be nutriated.
So if you go to a doctor, that's what's
going to happen. You know, like the old
story, you you know, guy takes a snake
home for a pet and the snake bites him.
He says, "You knew I was a snake when
you brought me in. What the heck do you
expect?" You go to a doctor, you get
doctorred. You don't go to a doctor for
nutrition. You go to a doctor when you
have an emergency. Now, unfortunately,
we go to doctors sometimes because we're
conditioned, we're programmed, we're
hypnotized, we're entranced, we're
marketed this way. We go to a doctor for
everything.
But really the job of a doctor is to
take care of us if we're have an
emergency. And that's really what that
their role should be. If you have an
emergency because they're doctoring us,
that means they're juryrigging us. You
know, if you're the bumper off your car
is falling off, you get some bailing
wire and you wrap it up and you keep the
bumper up. You got to do that. That's
what you have to do. And if you have a
90%
uh uh clog in your artery, you have to
get a bypass. That's what you have to
do. The job, our job is to help people
say they don't have they don't they're
not clogged up and they don't have to
have a bypass. So this idea that
nutrition will interfere with your drugs
comes from this misunderstanding
that not that we as individuals it's not
our misunderstanding it's the medical
model's misunderstanding and partially
it's for liability reasons that says
that an a nutrient is like a drug. They
put everything into the category of
drugs. But from a biological
perspective, medications and nutrients
are comp are apples and oranges. One
compels, one facilitates.
Now, it turns out that when you
facilitate chemistry,
you make the compulsion
less imperative. In other words, you
relax the the the need for compulsion.
So nutrients will make drugs work
better, more efficiently because they
they're creating a pathway. So the drug
doesn't have to be as forceful. So in
that way if you're for example taking a
high blood pressure an anti-hypertensive
like a beta blocker and you start using
magnesium or niacin which is a vasod
diilator which will drop the blood
pressure you may gradually have to
reduce your blood pressure medicine
which is a good thing because remember a
blood pressure medicine is a poison. A
nutrient is a facilitator. So you really
want to go with facilitators, not
poisons. And the more facilitating you
do, the less poison you're going to
need. What's more
is nutrients are pleotropic.
What does that mean? Pleotropic means
multifunctional.
So you take your EFAs because you want
your blood to move more efficiently. Not
only will that allow you to be on less
blood thinner,
but it will also improve your skin,
it will also improve your steroid, the
health of your steroid hormones. It'll
also improve your liver function. In
other words, it will facilitate not just
the blood the the the u the chemical
reaction that you're targeting, i.e. the
blood, it'll improve overall health
because nutrients are are function for
are important for every single cell of
the body. So you're going to improve the
health of every single cell of the body.
This makes them completely different
than drugs and
orders of magnitude more important and
relevant than drugs. That all being
said, if you have an emergency, and this
is where, you know, medication can be
life-saving. Obviously, mo most of us
recognize that. You have an emergency,
don't play around. You know, if you have
a serious blood thinning problem or a
blood clotting problem, I should say,
don't play around. Blood clotser can
kill you. So if you have a if you have
congestive heart failure or atrial
fibrillation or some kind of
cardiovascular issue and your blood
tends to clot,
you're going to need a blood thinner.
But your goal, as I've always said, when
you're on a medication
for a chronic degenerative condition,
your goal is to gradually wean yourself
off that drug. And there's no there's no
strategy more effective than getting on
a nutritional supplement program that
will allow you to do that. So, got AIB
and they put you on Eloquis, you stay on
your Eloquis and you get your uh all the
strategies we talk about on this program
all the time. Keep the blood clean, work
on your leaky gut, make sure you're
using your EFAs and and other
nutritional supplements are important
for for the circulatory system. And over
time, hopefully not too long, depending
on how bad shape you are, gradually dial
down the medication
as you're dialing in the healthy blood
flow. And that should be the goal.
Nobody should ever be on a prescription
drug for the rest of their life even
though they tell you that. Now,
sometimes if you're, you know, you have
a kidney transplant or, you know, they
do something mechanically, they take
your thyroid out or something like that,
you may need to be on a medication for
the rest of your life. But other than
that, if you have an opportunity to wean
yourself down or at least take a minimal
dose, as low dose as possible, you want
to do that. And most doctors recognize
this because like I said, doctors
understand that they're using poison to
make you better. So they most doctors
will understand that. Your ER docs maybe
not so much. Um your older docs maybe
not so much, but most competent
physicians understand that prescription
drugs are a necessary evil uh at best.
And as you get healthier, they will want
you to wean yourself off. Most of them,
not all of them. And there's some drugs
that they consider more benign they
don't even care about like the statin
drugs. They'll leave you on those
forever. they'll just put you on those
um you know just routinely as part of
something called standards of care which
I guess bears mentioning in the sense
that if um if
a medication is part of your standard as
part of what's called standards of care
that means it's accepted practice to be
on a certain medication and they don't
put you on a statin drug
in the case of statin drugs as as the
topic that we're talking about they can
actually be sued if you have a heart
attack or something you say hey they
didn't put me on a statin drug and
that's part of standards of care. So, it
gets into the liability question. A lot
of times docs because of mal malpractice
would rather heir on the side of putting
you on more drugs than risking their uh
risking uh being sued or an increase in
their insurance. Does that make sense?
Drugs are your best or nutrients are
your best friend. Drugs are a necessary
evil. That's pretty much if you want to
put it into simple terms, that's pretty
much pretty much explains it. Nutrients
are not optional. They're essential.
Drugs are not essential. There's no
essential nutrient or essential drug.
There's lots of essential nutrients.
>> So, you had mentioned that nutrients are
facilitators. They help facilitate the
body to do what the body was designed to
do.
>> Specifically cells. But yes, that's
true.
>> Okay. Cells. And the body is made up of
how many cells?
>> Lots and lots. 100 trillion. Nobody
really know. You know, you hear these
numbers banning about. Nobody's ever
counted the amount of cells in
somebody's body. So, nobody really
knows, but the estimates are between 50
and 100 trillion, which is ridiculous,
right? How long do you think it would
take you to count to 100 trillion,
Rebecca, if you count one by one,
>> you know? I don't know if I could in a
lifetime.
>> Just take a guess.
>> Okay. 90 years.
>> 90 years. 32 million.
>> 20 years.
>> 32 million years.
>> Oh my goodness.
million years.
>> Yeah. Like I said, not in my lifetime.
>> Yeah.
>> Pretty easy. So,
>> just as kind of a quick summary, folks,
you take your supplements, it allows it.
>> Can Let me Can I I'm sorry. Can I say
one more thing? This sometimes I'll put
you when you go to the hospital, that's
how you get off all your medic off all
your nutrients. So, what's the thinking
there? You need the nutrients for a
better operation or better prognosis.
The nutrients will help you heal.
They'll help your body recover much
faster.
So, what's the logic to taking you off
the nutrients? The nutrients are a wild
card that the doctors don't want to have
to deal with. With the drugs, they have
a control. They know exactly because the
drugs are all report. There's all kinds
of studies on the drugs and they have a
little bit more understanding of what
the drugs are going to do to the body.
So, they don't want a wild card. And to
them, to the doctors, fairly or
unfairly, they say they see the
nutrients as another version of drugs.
So they see the nutrients as interfering
somehow with the drugs inaccurately.
But that's how they're trained. That's
how they're trained. And remember, when
you go to a physician, and it's kind of
hard, you know, I for somebody like me
to say this because I've been studying
this stuff for a long time. And you
know, when you haven't studied it for a
while,
it's hard for you to push back against
the doctor. But it's your right to take
whatever you want to take. If you need
nut, if you believe you need nutrients
to make your surgical procedure go
better, it's your right to take them.
You know, the doctor may say, "Hey, then
that's fine. I don't want to operate on
you." That's his right to say that, too.
But you don't have to feel compelled.
Although, you know, I know it's a little
easier for me to say that than it is for
an average person to say that because
it's kind of intimidating to talk to a
physician. You know, there's this
comedian, Brian Rean. He talks about how
intimidating is when he talks to his
doctor. He's always like, you know, how
come you did how come your cholesterol
is high? And I don't know, doc, I'm
sorry. You know, it's like kind of we we
feel this kind of paternal infanti
infantilization relationship with our
position. And it's encouraged partially.
It's encouraged, but you know, he's
you're paying them. They're not paying
you. You're paying them. So, it's your
right to say, "Hey, I'm staying on this,
and if you don't want to operate on me,
I'll find somebody who does, but I'm
staying on my vitamin C because I need
vitamin C to heal." And in fairness,
there are not all doctors are tyrants.
You know, there are some who will
understand this.
>> And I know you've said it more than
once, but Dr. Wallik has said it. The
doctors work for you.
>> Yes. Yes, exactly.
You're their boss. You're their daddy.
They're not yours.
>> It's amazing how that role seems to have
been switched, isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I'm so glad that we are here to be
able to share information that empowers
people to take back their human rights.
um to be able to neutrify themselves and
to support the body and to facilitate
the cells to do what they were designed
to do and that is continually regenerate
and as they as long as they have what
they need they're going to regenerate
healthier and healthier, right?
>> Yes.
>> Something like
>> so hopefully Yeah, that's the whole
point.
>> Awesome. Well, we do have some questions
coming in um in a comment. So, Wyoming,
>> let's hear the comment. What's What is
the comment?
>> Um, so out on YouTube, Wyoming, Annie is
saying, "Like what doc repeated,
please?" Oh, she says, "Please list the
foods on the do not eat list for new
listeners. It is important as a starter.
Then they can do a food diary as they
learn." And
>> who who was saying that? Is that a
caller or a viewer?
>> Um, she Wyomi Wyomi. Oh, yeah. Yes,
>> I know. Yes, I remember way I think a
AJ's got a question. Somebody else has a
qu
>> Yes, they do.
>> Okay.
>> Um, but folks, if you wanted to see the
good foods, bad foods list, go to
dailywithdoc.com.
Right there in the menu, drwick10. Good
foods, bad foods. Um, easy to find.
Print it off and it's right there for
you. So, let's go to area code 209.
Go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Area code 209.
>> Where's Where's area code 209? Is that
Idaho?
>> Uh, no. Washington, Miss M.
>> Oh, Washington. Hi.
>> No, no, no, no. 209's not Washington.
>> Where's 209?
>> Um, so on the phone you might need to
hit star six to unmute.
>> Or is it star seven to unmute?
>> Um, but while she's It is star six.
Fantastic.
So, area code 209, Ms. M, are you able
to hit star six to unmute, please?
And while she's working on that, let's
go on over to AJ with his question. AJ,
uh, for Mr. Ben, what's this thing I
hear I keep hearing about this metabolic
syndrome? But before uh you you go into
that, I have one particular question. Um
is there a particular reason
maybe because it's viewed as a medicine
or for some reason why a company might
tout that they would not put vitamin A
in their skin um
>> in their skin product?
>> Yeah.
>> Where did you hear that? That's an
interesting question. I'm just curious
where you heard that and I'll answer and
then I'll answer it.
>> I'm not going to tell you. What do you
mean you're not gonna tell me?
>> I'm not gonna tell you. I heard it a
secret. Is it a secret?
>> It It is a secret. I heard yesterday on
on Daily with Doc when we had one of the
new uh uh folks, one of the new skin
care companies on and
>> they said they don't use vitamin A
>> was one of the things listed amongst the
bad things that they don't use. Vitamin
A was on that list. And I was curious to
know,
>> well, I'm not going to get I'm not going
to attack anybody's understanding the
skin, but clearly somebody doesn't
understand the skin very well. But there
are a couple things. First of all, there
was a study that came out a few years
ago, a nonsensical stupid study, uh, on
retinal palmitate, which is a form of
vitamin A in the sun. And they found
that when they when they pounded mice
with a bunch of retin palatate and put
them out in the sun, they're more prone
towards getting lesions. So there was
some controversy around vitamin A in the
sun. And that's one thing that they may
have been thinking about. Second of all,
there are uh there's a a couple of forms
of vitamin A. They're very active. One
is called retinoic acid, which you may
have heard of. It's the active
ingredient renea. Another is called
retinol. They are both of those
stupendously
overthe-top
valuable for anti-aging and for
preventing skin cancer and for replacing
missing vitamin A and cells. Uh
incredibly valued. And this is the
problem with people in the skincare
business. Unfortunately, if you don't
study the skin inside and out, I've been
studying for 45 years deeply. You follow
mainstream ideas and the mainstream on
the skin and we should talk about this
sometime is very fascinating. The st the
the modern skincare business was born uh
at the turn of the 20th century by a
little old lady who came from um who
came from literally who came from no not
Estee Lauder but she was she was there
at the beginning. No, she was a little
old lady who came from Poland by way of
Australia and the UK and she came to the
United States at the turn of
>> Rubenstein.
>> Yes. How did you know that? Have you
heard me?
>> Have I told you this story?
>> I love the Helen and Rubenstein
Foundation. They sponsor PBS. So,
>> okay. So, I don't want to if I've told
the story before, I don't want to, you
know, I don't want to bore anybody.
Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. So, so
anyway, Helina Rubenstein, she was she
didn't have a lot she didn't have money
a lot of money. But in in Europe,
something very interesting. Are we okay
talking about the history of skincare
here? Is that something that Go is
appropriate.
>> Are you sure it's appropriate? I don't
want to bore anybody. I find it
fascinating personally.
>> Go for it.
>> So anyway, so Helina Rubenstein came
from uh Poland by way of UK, Australia,
the UK to the United States to New York
and she'd have a lot of money and she
had something that actually turned out
to be better than money. In Europe, um,
skincare had been practiced by families
because the skincare cream, the standard
skincare product was invented in Europe
by a by the Roman physician Galen at the
turn of the mill year 100 AD after
Christ. Um, and so for eons, thousands
of years in various in homes, uh,
families would make skincare products.
They didn't know anything about the
skin, of course. They didn't know
anything about cells. They didn't know
how to make the skin healthy. They knew
how to combine wax and oil and and rub
stuff on the skin to make the skin feel
feel good pretty much like we do today.
And Selena Rubenstein didn't have any
money, but she had a recipe for a
skincare product that her family had
been making. And this was the turn of
the 20th century. There's no skincare
business. In fact, up until the turn of
the 20th century, there was no it was
very difficult to get consumer goods.
There were no consumer goods. It was
there was a lot more people than there
were goods. But right around the 20th
beginning of the 20th century that
started to change with the industrial
revolution and all of a sudden there we
we figured out how to make things and as
we figured out how to make things we had
to sell things because all for the first
time in history there were more things
than there were people. So there was
this idea hey we got we got all these
things let's figure out how to way a way
to get people to buy the things so we
can make money. Thus was born
advertising and marketing. And so at the
turn of the 20th century, a bunch of
things, a confluence of a bunch of
different factors kind of blended
together. First of all, the industrial
revolution, more commodities than there
were people. So advertising and
marketing had to had to get going.
Secondly, technology was starting to get
going. Electricity had just started. You
know, think about how think about the
mindset of somebody who was born in the
or who was alive in the year 1900. All
of a sudden there's electricity and you
could turn lights on. I mean, before
then, you had to go kill whales and get
candles and and and torches and, you
know, lanterns. Now, all of a sudden,
you hit a switch and are you kidding me?
All of a sudden, there's light. That was
considered a miracle. Top all that,
there were cars. The the the the Model
T's and people were driving. Well, then
they were riding on horses. All of a
sudden, you got cars now. Then there was
airplanes. Oh my god, people are flying
all of a sudden. Can you imagine the
mindset of somebody who's like alive at
this time flying things and and and cars
and uh electricity and on top of all
that you got Albert Einstein coming up
with a theory of relativity and quantum
and and all of a sudden there was this
mindset and then oh to add that you got
doctors and you got drugs all of a
sudden and you got these antibiotics and
you got these this incredible
um explosion of technology. We think we
have an incredible explosion today.
Well, back then it was just it was
mindboggling what was going on. And add
to that, you had magazines and you had
movies and you had movie stars and you
had celebrities. So there was this this
sea change in how the world operated and
enter into the world Helina Rubenstein.
And she said, "Hm, now maybe people will
buy skincare products. Maybe they'll be
they'll buy my skincare products. I'll
start to market my skincare products."
And she created this story around this
old silly cream she had that her family
had been making for for you know
generations. And she said that this
cream that she now sold was invented by
a famous doctor in Romania who went
through the Carpathian mountains and
picked these magical herbs and he put
them together and now you can use this
cream and your skin will glow and be
beautiful. And nobody ever heard of
anything like this. And guess what? It
caught on and Helina Rubenai started to
dress herself up in a lab coat and she
started to dress her uh employees. She
had a little little kind of a spa going,
a salon going. This one of the the
salons were starting to open up now. And
she dressed her salon employees in lab
coats and they were became very medical
and she portrayed herself as a very
medical person, a very scientific
person, creating what's called a
narrative and a story around skincare.
and it caught on and she started to sell
a lot of skincare products because the
people were starting to get money. You
know, this is right before the stock
market crash. People were investing in
the stock market. The economy was good
and so she started selling a lot of
skincare products not knowing squat
about the skin enter into the f and she
started to invent things. She started to
come up with ideas for example she came
up with this idea of dry skin, sensitive
skin, oily skin. Sound familiar people?
This is all Helina Rubenstein making
this stuff up, combination skin. Uh, and
then into the world of skin care entered
uh, Elizabeth Ardan and then Estee
Lauder and they brought with them this
idea of um, rituals, clean and tone and
moisturize and sampling free samples of
products and associating their products
with celebrities and having celebrities
endorse it. And that whole model of skin
care progressed for generations and it's
still with us today. And guess what? It
doesn't work. If you really want to
understand how to treat the skin
topically, you've got to study biology.
You've got to study biochemistry. You've
got to study cell chemistry. You've got
to study the skin. You've got to study
the immune system. You've got to study
the circulatory system. But
unfortunately the the world is such that
nobody wants to study biology. Nobody
wants to study biochemistry. Nobody
wants to study uh organic chemistry.
Nobody wants to study the circulatory
system and the skin. But they can sell
skincare products. So what they do now
is they'll read something on Facebook or
on these days on AI and they'll put it
together and they'll sell you a skincare
product knowing nothing about the skin.
And I don't know this company that
you're talking about. And I don't want
to attack any companies, but the vast
majority of skincare is like that. And
because we don't study chemistry either
as consumers and we don't study organic
chemistry, we just do whatever whatever
what everybody says. So it's a very
sneaky nasty business unfortunately
because anybody can be in it and
skincare products have very high margin
and that's unfortunate. Now I'm a
compounding pharmacist and my specialty
is dermatology and I've been studying
how to make the skin he how to heal the
skin from burns from traumas and for
skin diseases both internally and
topically for 45 years and I can tell
you the vast majority in fact 99.99%
of what you hear about skin care is
completely wrong and that's unfortunate
and while that you may be listening out
there and say that's an assertion hey
Ben you're just making an assertion I'll
prove it to you the proof is is that we
have thousands probably close to 10,000
different skincare companies and
probably close to 50,000 different
products maybe more that are available
to people and with all those products
are we happy with our skin generally
speaking no we have we spend 10 billion
dollars a year moisturizing creams in
this country and everybody has dry skin
but if you have a there are people have
moisturizers in their locker and in
their purse and in their medicine
cabinet and their office in in their car
and three in the in their vanity in
their behind the mirror and and
everybody has dry skin because it
doesn't work. Skincare is based on this
old idea of rub stuff on the skin and
hope for the best. So, for anybody who
ever tells you not to put a vitamin on
your skin for whatever reason and put
puts it on a list of bad things, I'd
like to talk to them because I don't
want to attack anybody, you know, not
knowing, but that's just ridiculous and
it's it's irresponsible to say something
like that. As far as vitamin A goes,
it's one of the skin's most important
vitamins. Vitamin A is actually stored
in the skin when you put it on the skin.
You can actually replace
vitamin A that's missing by putting it
on your skin. In other words, if you're
depleted in vitamin A, you can actually
put on your skin and your skin will
store it and and uh in a reservoir to
replace what's depleted. Vitamin A is
critical for protecting you from skin
cancer. It's used to treat actinic
kerattosis, which is pre-kin cancer.
Vitamin A is an epigenetic molecule that
will turn on the genes to make collagen.
The list of benefits of vitamin A from
the skin are as long as your arm.
Although I will say that the cosmetic
version of vitamin A which is called
retinyl palatate is nowhere near as
effective as the active form of vitamin
A which is retinoic acid and the
precursor of retinoic acid which is
retinol. And as far as vitamin A goes
that's something we study a lot of in
far dermatological vitamin A we study a
lot of in pharmacy school because it's a
it's a treatment for acne as well as for
psoriasis um and um as I say actinic
keratossis um and I've been studying
vitamin A specifically. So, I know a lot
about dermatological vitamin A and I
absolutely love love love it and I use
it a lot. So, I hope that answers I hope
that answers your question.
>> That Thank you for that abbreviated
version of that.
>> That was abbreviated. Yes,
>> that's it was. And then uh uh LP
Billingham has a question on YouTube.
>> Yeah. Well, I was actually waiting for
Becca to inter interrupt me on that
because
I was just actually paying her back for
Monday night, but she doesn't even
remember. The days are running into each
other. Farmer suspend. Uh, will I see
you on Monday night, Farmus?
>> Yes. Yes, you absolutely will see me on
that.
>> Do we do we have um the land down under?
>> Uh, no. No land down under.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> Oh.
All right. I remember, AJ. I absolutely
remember. Um, let's see if we can get
area code 209 to unmute one more time.
I've sent a request over. Hit star six
if you don't mind.
You have your heart hand up. While we're
waiting still, um, Hattie wants to know,
"How do you address the big C in the
colon?"
>> Big C. We do have to say the big We have
to say the big C for YouTube.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> For YouTube.
>> For YouTube. All right.
>> And she wants to know if a detox is
recommended.
>> Detox is always recommended. What's the
best detox?
>> Stop eating.
>> Best detox. Fast. When you fast, your
body cleans itself out out through
autophagy.
It cleans it. It's the best detox there
is. Fasting. Um, obviously you can't.
And f, by the way, one of the things
that they'll tell you when you're when
you have cancer is not to fast. The
medical folks will tell you because
they're afraid that you'll waste away.
Again, misunderstanding
weight with health. And so when you're
fasting, you will obviously lose weight,
but you'll lose you're not going to lose
muscle until you go until you're into
starvation. And you don't want to go
into starvation. So most of us can use a
good fast and and what we'll lose is not
going to be u is not going to be muscle.
So fasting is the best is the best
detox. uh water, good clean water,
hydrogen water ideally or or um or plant
derived mineral water, structured water
is another strategy for clear for
clearing things out. Um clays can be
used to detox and and really we don't
talk about this a lot, but we should.
Plantder derived minerals are
detoxifying
and they're clean, they clean out the
blood, just plant derived minerals. So,
and that's a that's a very important
benefit of plant- derived minerals is um
their detoxifying properties. So, yes,
uh detox is great. Uh colon cancer is
cancer the colon obviously. So, don't
put things in your colon
>> as best as you can.
>> I'm sorry, the C word. The C word. So,
yeah, don't put things in your colon.
The less you put in your colon, the
easier the easest
system in general. So that's really the
most important strategy
you I there are introvenous nutrients
that I would if I if that was me I would
be using IV vitamin C high doses I'd
also be using IV glutathione
and then as far as nutrients go oral
nutrients go um you can uh selenium
which helps you build glutathione and
acetylcyine which helps you build
glutathione
um glycine very very underappreciated
amino acid these are all found in the TM
PMR shake or in um any of the any of the
protein shakes, you'll find these amino
acids. Arginine probably would be
helpful. Um challenge your body with
nutrients is basically the idea. And
stay away from the the the bad foods.
Whoever was asking about the bad foods,
you want to stay away from those.
Although the bad food list is very very
basic, very minimum. It's like the
lowhanging fruit. There's lots more that
you want to stay away from.
>> Yeah. I absolutely um
>> also Also, sorry to interrupt you. Um,
the uh fried oils are very very
sensitizing for the intestinal lining.
Oh, another one I forgot. This is uh
there's a fatty acid that's really
really important for the cells of the
intestine called butyric acid, but
you'll find that in um in butter. And
you can also use coconut oil, which
contains some butyrate. Probably
probably not a lot, but probably some
butyrate. Um, and then also, uh, I think
we have a GABA is a form of butyrate.
You might want to use that. Um, and then
also the amino acid glutamine, which is
a component of the glutathione molecule,
is also important for intestinal health.
>> So, as you're fasting, you can still
take your oral supplementation.
>> Yeah, definitely. Fasting is for
calories. When you fast, you're fasting
for calories. Supplements are
non-caloric.
And then you mentioned the TMR shake
which is a meal replacement which is
>> Yes.
TMR
>> TMR total meal replace and that's going
to have um the basic nutrients that will
allow you to eat less food plus it will
have all the nutrients for the important
for the colon. Uh and the whey protein
is especially helpful for the colon. TMR
shake uses whey protein.
>> All right. Now, I I've got, you know,
I've had a few people question, you
know, we're working with dairy, whey is
dairy, but casein protein. You're not
supposed to have casein. What is, what's
your thoughts on that?
>> Um,
casein is the problematic protein in
whey, in a milk, in dairy. Quin is
casein is the little chunks in cottage
cheese.
>> Quin forms little chunks. whey protein
whey uh is the whey is the water
refraction of of dairy and the protein
concentration of whey is very high and
it's a very very easy to process protein
very bioavailable protein.
So, you're saying the fact that I love
cottage cheese?
>> Well, not everybody has a problem. No,
not every pro not everybody has a
problem with uh with cassine.
>> Okay, just checking. And let me see if
we have any more questions here. Let's
try one more time. Area code 209. Go
ahead and try to unmute with star six if
you don't mind.
As you are on a phone, make sure the the
dial numbers are showing and hit the
star pan the star and then this number
six that should unmute you.
Um and if I have any coaches that are
out on the different platforms if you
see any questions because I do not see
those questions unless you share them
with me. Um and oh so Haddie did mention
that this individual with the big C is a
vegan.
>> Okay. Okay. So, I would be I would be
very careful if they're a vegan because
there are vegan um vegan friendly foods
that can be hard on the on the colon,
particularly the FODMAPs.
You're familiar with FODMAPs, those
sugars that that induce SIBO. Um yeah,
and this is a kind of another myth out
there. People are vegan sometimes
believe that that's a healthier way to
eat. Not necessarily. So,
uh, vegan foods, vegan friendly foods
tend to be rich in in the FODMAP sugars
first of all, like beans and such. Uh,
and they also contain lectins, plant
defense molecules that can be
problematic. So, I'm not saying to be a
vegan or not to be a vegan, but just
don't get be under laboring under the
illusion that veganism is somehow
automatically better for you than than
being an omnivore, which is eating
everything.
Now, being a carnivore and eating only
meat, that's another issue, and that's
probably not a great thing either. But
there's this there's this kind of kind
of self-righteousness about veganism
that, you know, oh, I'm a vegan. I only
eat vegan foods that makes it sound like
that's the healthier way to eat. Not
true. There are plenty of plant foods
that are seriously immune activating and
seriously inflammatory, especially, by
the way, for the skin. So, you know, if
you're a vegan out there, that more
power to you. there's not, you know, do
whatever you want to do, but don't be
under the illusion that it's
automatically better for you to eat
vegetables or to be a vegan than it is
to uh than to be an omnivore. And on top
of all that, if you're vegan, you're
going to have a problem with certain
nutrients. So, vegans tend to be
deficient in torine, for example, which
is an amino acid that's only found in um
animal foods. Um, vitamin B12 sometimes
can be a problem for vegans if uh
although vitamin B12 is found in the
soil and it should be in plants, but
because of the way plants are grown and
cultivated with pesticides and such to
kill the bacteria in the soil, a lot of
B12 deficiencies can occur in uh in
vegans. Iron sometimes can be a problem
for vegans. So, it's not all that great
to you know, there are problems
associated with vegetable foods as much
as there are problems associated with
animal foods. um for this person who's a
vegan,
you know, they're going to have a
problem if they want to stay up vegan,
uh there's not, you know, chances are
the colon cancer had something to do
with SIBO and FODMAPs. And chances are
this this there's a person, and I don't
know. I can't say. I'd have to talk to
this person, but the possibility is
there that they've been dealing with
SIBO, small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth, secondary to ingestion of
lots of FODMAPs kinds of foods from
being a vegan. I'd have to ask. I don't
know. But grains beans,
um, nuts, uh, legumes of all kinds, all
of those can be a problem. And those
those are the ways vegan vegans eat a
lot of those kinds of foods.
So, I've been doing a lot of research
into vegans because somebody gives me a
hard time about eating meat. Um, and
yes, AJ.
So,
one thing that they say is that there's
only nine essential nutrients that the
body needs. We say there's 12 and as you
mentioned to
>> what do they say? What do they say? The
three that aren't that they that they
don't need.
>> I that that I can't remember off the top
of my head.
>> Okay.
>> Um so I I was kind of um I was like,
"Oh, wow. They're missing three." And
another one is when you take a legume
and add it to a grain, it's supposed to
create a perfect protein.
>> That's old news. That that was a lady
named Francis Le Francis Lee. I think
she wrote a book called diet forget the
name of the book she wrote where she
talked about how you could take all your
amino acids eventually and your body
would put them together to get the amino
acids. Diet for a small planet I think
was the name of her book a long time
ago. That's kind of people don't pay too
much attention to that anymore. This
idea that you could get your amino acids
separately. Um but but like you say um
conditionally essential nutrients are
going to be difficult. Torine is not
essential, but it's conditionally
essential. And there's no torine in in
dairy food in u vegan foods. It's only
found in animal foods. So, you know,
maybe they could supplement with torine
if they wanted to. It's just a little
trickier if you're if you're vegan. The
real problem I see with veganism is the
legumes and the FODMAPs.
>> Okay.
>> And and the lectins. The I'm sorry, the
legumes, the lectins, and the FODMAPs.
Those are the biggest problems that I
see with with um with veganism. And by
the way, legumes are, you know, they're
not a bad food necessarily, but a lot of
people have problems with them.
>> Okay. So, another thing that caught my
attention is you mentioned that there's
a lot of plants that can cause skin
issues.
>> Lots.
>> What are some top ones that you
>> Beans? Beans are the worst for skin
issues, but also flowers.
>> Beans. Green beans.
>> No. um green be I don't know the drawing
doesn't have much to do with it but any
kind of bean any legume beans or legumes
okay are very lectin rich
>> so proteindense vegan foods which beans
are a protein-dense vegan food is going
to can be problematic
uh especially for acne or it's not
really acne looks like acne is treated
like acne there's a skin condition that
unfortunately gets lumped into this
category of acne true acne is T-zone.
The T-zone is your forehead and the
middle of your face. And it's had it um
it's uh causes little pimples. They call
them comedones technically. Uh and these
little pimples can be white heads or
they can be blackheads, but they're
discreet. They're like individual units.
There's another skin condition that gets
called acne, but it really is not acne.
And it's not based on in the same
mechanisms of action that cause true
acne, which is the T-zone, comedonal
acne. And it's rashy. You've all seen
this, you know, especially it occurs all
over the face, particularly in the cheek
areas, the sides. Sometimes it's cystic.
This is not acne. Although it gets
treated as acne in the sense that you'll
get the same medicine, you'll get the
same topicals as you as if you had acne
and it doesn't work because it's not
acne. It's an inflammatory condition
that's the manifestation of an activated
immune system.
When you have your when you're d when
you have an immune activation
because of something you're eating,
those immune factors, cytoines and
inflammatory chemicals and molecules
will go floating around in your blood
and they'll come to rest in your skin.
And that's these rashy these this kind
of it's a rashy red bumpy condition
versus individual discrete pimples. This
condition which gets called acne is
almost always associated with something
you're eating pretty much always I would
say maybe there's some exceptions and
that something is very often legumes but
also grains also dairy also eggs they
can all be responsible for this kind of
reaction as well. The good news about
this is once you eliminate the legumes
and the dairy or whatever the trigger
is, this condition disappears
and it never comes back unless you go
back to your legumes or your dairy or
your grains. And that's what's really
cool about the co the traditional acne,
the comedonal acne or what's really
acne. That's a little trickier because
that involves insulin, that involves
testosterone,
that involves um digestive health, that
involves a whole bunch of different
factors and that's a little trickier to
deal with. Although that can be dealt
with very effectively through nutrition.
Um the uh the other kind of acne that
you can that goes away almost right
instantaneously. Your skin can improve
as soon as you eliminate and and let me
tell you something the psychological
damage of this condition can be it can
be lifetime. You can have a lifetime of
psych psychological debilitation from
having this kind of condition when you
were a child or when you were a teenager
when you were a kid. It could be really
really awful. So to have somebody who
has this condition for you know their
whole life or at least their whole life
post adolescence or sometimes even baby
somes even babies get this condition and
then all of a sudden it disappears. The
the kind of joy and bliss and ecstasy
these kids have these people have when
they their skin clears. It's hard to
even put you can't describe it. It's
amazing. And by the way, this condition
often times when it's not controlled
will show up on the back and show up on
the neck and show up even all the way
down to the buttocks, even on the butt
sometimes. And it could be really bad
and and you can kind of get a kind of an
understanding of what I'm talking about.
If you ever seen people who abuse
steroid drugs and in in locker rooms
when when I was in high school, we could
tell who was doing the steroids because
they would all have acne on the back
called backne, right? And that's another
that's related to this kind of food
condition. Um the steroid acne, which
again is not really true acne.
>> So, one of my co-hosts says it's not
acne, it's beanie. Thank you so much,
AJ.
>> And um Phyllis, thank you for putting in
the additional three. So, the three
essential
amino acids that Dr. Wallik has added as
being essential are arginine,
torine, and tyrrosine.
>> Um, arginine and torine are they're
conditionally essential. There's a Have
you heard the term conditionally
essential?
>> Well, yeah, you just said it.
>> No, I know, but you you know what that
means? Conditionally essential.
>> I don't know the technical definition of
it, but you're going to tell us. I know
you are.
>> Yes. Conditionally essential means um
and those three amino acids are
conditionally essential means you don't
have a disease if you don't have
arginine
I'm sorry if you don't have tyrrosine or
or what do you say arginine tyrroscine
what was the other one and torine butine
>> but you will be maximally healthy other
body can make small amounts of it but
one of the things that we talk about doc
this is what I've I've been talking
about since I graduated pharmacy school
and Dr. Walt's been talking about it is
this idea of giving the body high doses
of things. So, and when we talk about
the body, we're really talking about
cells. As I said earlier, it's the
cells. And when a cell has abundance,
it can make things abundantly.
When it has a small amount of nutrients,
a small amount of raw materials, it's
going to conserve. And you don't want to
sell to conserve. It's kind of like if
you have a lot of money in the bank,
you're going to take a vacation. You're
going to buy a house. You're going to
buy a car. You're going to give your
neighbors money, your friends money,
your kids money. You're going to be
spending money. You're going to be
buying things. You're going to be doing
things. When you have less money, you
conserve. You hold on to things. You
don't go out and you don't buy a house
and you you don't, you know, buy new
clothes and all the things that you buy
with your money. What we want to do is
we want the cell to feel abundant like
it has plenty of stuff. So yes, you
know, you can get by with a certain
amount of tyroscene, but if you have
more, your cell can make more nutrients
and tyrroscine is a raw material for
making very important brain chemicals
among other things. So you want to have
you want the cell to feel like life is
good. There's so much. And that's why
when people say, "Oh, you're just going
to have expensive urine, you know, blah
blah blah." You want your urine
expensive. That means you got plenty.
You want your cells to say, "Life is
good." You don't want your cells saying,
"Well, we only have a little bit, so we
can't really make a lot of dopamine here
or we can't really make a lot of
collagen because we got to conserve
things." That's you don't want that. And
unfortunately, in the stand with the
standard American diet, that's what our
cells are saying. So, Dr. Wallick has
been saying and myself is pound the body
with nutrients. And yes, you may have
excrete a little bit extra, but it's
worth it. It's your insurance.
>> Yeah. And your body doesn't feel like
it's in starvation mode either.
>> Exactly. The cells. Remember, it's the
cells, not the body. It's the cells.
Yes, the cells, you don't want the cells
to feel like, you know, there's not a
lot and they eventually they'll shut
down. Eventually, they'll die before
they die, they kind of slow down a
little bit. They go into dormcancy. They
don't they don't uh work as hard. They
don't expend as many resources because
there's not a lot of resources there.
So, you want the cells to feel like life
is good. And that's the idea of of these
non these conditionally essential amino
acids. They're not necessarily essential
in the sense that a disease will happen
if you don't have them, but they're
conditionally essential in the sense
that if you have more, you're going to
function better. Your cells will.
>> Gotcha. And for those who are not
familiar with legumes, we're talking
kidney beans, black beans, garbanzo
beans, lentils, peas,
>> peanuts, soy,
>> peanuts, soy, uh white beans, navy
beans.
>> Yeah. Beans. Beans.
>> Cookie beans.
>> Yeah. Beans in general are are legumes
and also um and then peanuts are beans.
People don't realize that, but peanuts
are beans.
>> Lentils are beans. Yes, lentils are
beans.
>> And beans are a great food. I don't want
to I don't want to cast dispersions on
lentils and beans. They're amazing
foods. They're deeply rich in protein,
which is unusual. You know, vegetables
typically don't have lots or plant
material typically doesn't have lots of
protein in them. Beans and nuts do. And
that that makes them very valuable. But
whenever you have lots of protein in a
food, a protein richch food, often
times, not always, but often times those
are foods that you can react to. Eggs
and dairy,
>> right? And I know
>> examples,
>> lentils are mentioned in the Bible,
>> so
>> probably, but they were a different they
were a different lentil, I'm sure,
because the soil was different. A lot of
things were different. You know, when
they talk about biblical foods, you hear
people saying, "Oh, I'm going to eat
like in the Bible." Those foods don't
exist even if they're called the same
thing. And by the way, for as far as
vegans go and vegetarians go, there's no
meat that people react to. Although
these days they have this alpha gal
thing. I don't know if you heard of
that, but you know, the whole tick
thing. But for the most part, meats,
nobody reacts to meat. Nobody has meat
allergy. There's lots of tomato, you
know, nut allergies, bean allergies,
that kind of thing. But there's no meat
allergies, which is kind of ironic
because we don't hear that, you know. We
we hear that meat's a problem. Not this
meat, not the meat is perfect either,
you know. So, you got to be careful.
Well, that's why I always say the best
strategy is to eat as little as
possible. The less you eat, the longer
you live.
>> Well, and that reminds me, I have a
granddaughter who can eat meat all day
long as long as it's not shrimp, but
she's allergic to all these different
plants.
>> It's crazy. Yeah.
>> And oil,
>> which is good.
>> Um, we got a couple questions. Do you
have a hard stop?
>> Two o'clock.
>> Two o'clock. Okay. So, the first
question is coming from Heather on
YouTube. What is the cause of eczema,
please? Oh, eczema is so easy. So easy.
Eczema, in order to understand eczema,
you got to understand the skin a little
bit. So when we see the skin,
I sometimes wonder what people think of
when they see the skin. Like this is the
body's largest organ, which it's not.
It's the body's second largest organ.
But when you look at it, um, does that
look like an organ?
>> No.
>> It looks like a fine rapper.
>> It looks like a rapper, right? But it's
not. It's an organ. And it is just
absolutely packed with biochemistry act.
And um the biochemistry facilitates
movement.
So the skin even though it doesn't look
like it is layered, stratified like
lasagna, right? Or baklava. It's
layered. The bottom layer is where
living cells are. And this is the
surface of the skin. The skin's got
actually three major layers. It's got a
dead layer on the surface which acts
like a barrier. It's got a middle layer
which is where the barrier is developed
from and it's got a very bottom layer.
The bottom layer is like the bottom of
an iceberg. And if you ever seen
pictures of an iceberg, you got the tip
of the iceberg on the top and 90% of the
iceberg's underneath. Likewise with the
skin, 90% of the iceberg is underneath.
90% of the skin is called your dermis.
And that is where the blood is. That's
where the nerves are. If you ever if you
ever cut yourself and you see blood,
that's the dermis. That's where the
immune cells live. most of the immune
cells that that's where all the action
is happening. Collagen is there,
hyaluronic acid is there. That's really
the bulk of the skin. It's about as
thick as it's the bulk of the skin, but
it's about as thick as nine pieces of
paper. That's the bulk of the skin.
>> Wow.
>> On top of the skin, you have the epi or
top of the dermis, you have the epi
dermis. The epidermis is about as thick
as one piece of paper.
And on the very top, you have like a
coating. You ever seen apples at the
supermarket? They have a coating on
them. It's like the coating on the
surface. That is your stratum corneium.
That means the hard layer. And that's
about as thick as a tenth of a piece of
notebook paper. And that stratum
corneium is critical. Even though it's
ma largely made up of dead cells, lots
of action happening there. And the way
the skin works is things rise from the
bottom of the epidermis. Forget the
dermis. We're not going to talk about
that. Bottom of the epidermis up to the
top. Cells shed off and then they go up
to the top. Cell shed off. Cell up to
the top. And there's this movement. this
dynamism. Even though it doesn't look
like anything's happening, it's very
dynamic. There's lots of chemistry, lots
of movement, lots of biology, lots of
action that's happening. When you eat
the wrong foods, surprise surprise, or
you have intestinal health or digestive
health problems, what happens is those
molecules that are related to the immune
system that are are um induced by
activated immunity from eating milk or
dairy or whatever you're eating or from
changes in the bacteria in the
intestine, the molecules of the immune
system that are secreted in response to
the attack or the inflammation, they end
up in the blood and now they're floating
around in the And one of the places
where they were in invariably come out
of come out of the blood and get dumped
out into is the skin. Now that movement
is going to be disrupted because now you
have a bunch of inflammatory factors and
immune factors in the skin secondary to
the blood which is coming from the
intestine.
And so now this movement does not occur
as um as as easily or as much facility.
And you end up with with spaces on the
top because the cells aren't moving
upwards appropriately. viously end up
with little gaps. In addition to those
little gaps, because you have all these
inflammatory factors, your skin will
will be irritated and and it'll be
sensitized because you got all this
immune activity following the the
deposition from the blood, following the
uh attack in the intestine.
That sensitivity of the skin, that um
incomplete formation of the barrier, the
surface is called eczema. Now eczema is
not the real name. The eczema is the
colloquial name. The real name is
attopic dermatitis.
That's the technical name. We call it
eczema colloquially. But attopic
dermatitis
uh is the real name for eczema. So what
does that mean? Itis inflammation.
Derma skin. Dermatitis means inflamed
skin. Okay, we know that. But here's the
key. It's a topic. What does that mean?
Attopic.
A is a prefix for without or not. Topic
it means topical. So it tells you right
in the name. Attopic dermatitis is
dermatitis. Inflamed skin that's not
related to anything topical.
What's the opposite of topical?
>> Systemic. Internal.
>> Systemic.
>> It's an internal issue. And when we talk
about internal issues, we're talking
always about the blood which is comes
from the digestive system. So eczema for
and just as a quick digression is
associated with ear infections. It's
associated with respiratory infections.
It's uh not infections but respiratory
problems. It's associated with um
asthma. They all go together because
it's the same kind of mechanism. Instead
when you have asthma, instead of having
the immune issues in the skin, you have
it in the in the lungs. And when you
have ear infections, you have the immune
issue in the in the inner ear. So all of
these are connected and that's um and
that's why kids will oftentimes get ear
infections and asthma and and attopic
dermatitis or eczema at the same time.
So to answer the question, what do you
do? Work on digestive health. You have a
food diary associated with food with
fatty foods. The skin is very responsive
to essential fatty acids. EFAs are the
molecules of inflammation. So anytime
you have an inflammatory issue, you
essential fatty acids can be helpful and
then of course probiotics um I26
and then elimination of problem foods
via food diary. That's how you treat
eczema and it's very easy to treat.
Fatty vitamins can help too. Vitamins's
A and D, zinc and selenium can both be
helpful as well. Those are important for
skin health and for the immune system.
Um and then uh topically uh or not even
topically but internally and also
topically fucoid Z. You can use fugu
topically by breaking open a capsule and
putting it in water and putting it right
on your skin. Or you can use fucoid z
just by itself and that can be helpful
too. Protect against leaky gut. Look for
other health challenges that you can
work on. Create this whole triangulation
of other symptoms of other health
breakdowns that you can kind of put
together a a symptom management tree
that you can work with. Um and it's very
easy to deal with like acne. The skin is
very very very forgiving and so you
because it turns over so fast. So you
can do a lot of stuff with the skin and
if you do it correctly you'll never have
eczema or contact or attopic dermatitis
again. Uh the other kind of dermatitis
by the way is called contact dermatitis
and that's the kind of dermatitis that
occurs when something hits your skin to
nickel or talc or something like that.
Some people have contact dermatitis but
eczema is attopic dermatitis which right
in the name it tells you it's not
topical.
>> Okay.
>> Well we did have one more question. Can
we squeeze one more question?
>> Okay we'll do one more.
>> Okay. So, um, LPB
out on YouTube says that they are
dealing with MS and going to be taking
two.
>> That's not just one. That's just not
just one more question. MS MS I I'll
tell you quickly and we should talk
about it um you know maybe on on Monday
night. Well, let's talk about
autoimmunity on Monday night. AJ, so uh
MS is an autoimmune issue. All
autoimmune diseases are the same no
matter where they occur and they can
occur anywhere in the body. There's 100
plus different autoimmune diseases and
they can occur you know in the bone or
in the um skin or in the pancreas or you
know in the muscle or in the um in the
uh eyes or anywhere. MS occurs in the
nerves. It's still the same thing. Don't
worry about where the problem is. Just
worry about the problem. Autoimmunity
means for some reason the immune system
looks foreign. Doctors will say your
mother had it. That's the only reason.
We don't know what caused it. I'm
telling you what causes it. The uh the
autoimmune target in this case in MS um
the nerves uh somehow has been has been
modified to look for in. So what is this
modification?
The modification is stuff that gets
dumped into that area through the blood.
It always starts in the blood. In fact,
doctors will check for something called
circulating immune complexes to
determine if you have an autoimmune
disease. They'll check the blood for
immune factors in the blood. So, how do
immune factors get into the blood?
>> How else how else? It's a food issue.
And I we'll talk about it more Monday
night, but for this person, go get the
wall, a book called the walls protocol.
This is a book written by Dr. Terry
Walls, medical doctor, WHLS. The Walls
protocol W Ah LS Terry Walls. She cured
herself of MS by doing what? By fasting,
by taking her by uh changing her diet,
doing a food diet, all the things we
talk about here today. It's a great book
for anybody who has MS.
>> And would a healthy body, brain, and
heart pack be okay with that?
>> Oh, yeah. Nutrients, all the nutrients
are great. the the mighty 90 essential
nutrients are a must, but focus on the
digestive nutrients like the like um uh
I26 and ultimate enzymes, fucoy Z, all
of those. And if you Z, you might want
to consider that to be a digestive
health supplement among other things.
>> Okay.
>> We'll see you on Monday night.
>> Well, thank you so much, Pharmacist Ben
Fuches. And if I could get the co-host
up on the screen with me, that would be
absolutely fabulous. Um, and little the
second part of the question LP where
you're asking um, two healthy body packs
a month. When doc says a full dose a
day, is that each of everything at once?
No. So, your Beyond Tangy Tangerine and
Osteo FX, they can be taken together in
the same water. When you're looking at
two healthy body packs, usually that's
per body weight. So if you're over 150
pounds, Dr. Wallik would recommend two
of those healthy body packs, which means
you would take two doses of the tangy
tangerine and osteo. So do one in the
morning, one in the afternoon. For your
EFAs, the EFA plus, you're going to be
doing two, three times a day. for the
ultimate EFA taking two doses that's
going to be
uh three four two times three times a
day and for the selenium that's going to
be two three times a day. So it's not
just taking it all at once. You want to
spread it out throughout the day doing
double doses with food ideally for
especially your essential fatty acids
and the uh ultimate selenium. And some
people may get an upset stomach if you
take ultimate selenium on an empty
stomach. I don't but I know other people
who do. So hopefully that answers your
question thoroughly and you definitely
want to check in on Monday as pharmacist
Ben Fuches and AJ will be covering
autoimmunity conditions
Monday 900 p.m. Eastern.
AJ
900 p.m. Eastern. Go to
stream.dwithdoc.com.
You can watch it on Rumble. You can also
watch it on YouTube. So when you go to
the different platforms, make sure that
you do a search for Daily with Doc and
Becca and subscribe to that channel or
those channels so that you get
notifications. And if for some reason
it's not working on one platform, it'll
work on another. So it's okay to be
subscribed on multiple platforms. Again,
my name is Becca Dukes. As a certified
holistic health coach, and a certified
naturopathic practitioner, the director
of student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health, it is my honor to have
on the screen with me some of our
coaches. um all of them certified
holistic health coaches who have stepped
up taken this so serious that they are
consistent with us Wednesday, Thursday
and Friday as we are doing our live
programming here on Daily with Doc and
Becca. Um,
and they are available
by calling. And this is for people who
are not working with somebody already,
somebody that has not tried the
Youngevity products, somebody that was
not referred to this program by somebody
else. If you were referred by somebody
else, they are your person. Get back
with them. Chances are they may also be
one of our amazing health advocates who
cares about people because they cared
enough about you to share this program
with you. So get back and tell them
thank you and they're going to be the
first person you're going to start
asking questions to. If they don't know
answers and they're not already
associated with Youngevity, then feel
free to give us a call at 8559493377.
And one of these great individuals, plus
a few others may be the ones answering
your call. So, on the on with us today,
we have Marilyn, lovingly known as
Speedy Fingers, as she's doing the chat,
uh, putting lots of information into the
chat here live, which is only available
when you're here live with us in Zoom.
Again, that's Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday. Join us by going to
zoom.dwithdoc.com.
again, Zoom. Z O M period daily with Doc
period Tom. Um, you're going to have to
be signed into
Zoom and the first time register and the
next time you should be allowed in as
long as you're not on the restricted
list.
Um,
so thank you Ronin. Let me pick up where
I was what I was thinking. Uh we have M
Ruth Allen who is my executive
production manager making sure that
everybody's on task helping us to
coordinate our guests for our
programming. And if you're out watching
and you see that amazing graphic and our
pictures and everything, she's taking
the Zoom putting it with the graphics
which I have to give a shout out to IFC
delivers for creating our graphics and
logo for us. And then we're pushing it
out to the different locations and where
the stream is available.
Um, and we have Phyllis, one of the
pioneers in helping get Dr. Wallik on
the air. She and her husband Andy. Thank
you so much, Phyllis, for being here.
She's having some, I think, internet
issues that are that are a little on the
weak side, but she's still here and
hanging in there. She's also putting
some information into the chat and
watching the platforms, bringing in
questions. And we have AJ, our digital
marketing director. Thank you, AJ, as
he's helping get us on all the different
platforms where digitally you can watch
us or hear us. So, thank you so much,
AJ, for all you do. Um, and again, he
has a show with pharmacist Ben on Monday
nights called Pharmacist Bin Bites. And
I don't know if they're changing the
name of that or what, but okay. Yes,
they're going to be changing the name of
that, but you want to plug in there as
they go back and, you know, it's almost
like a health comedy show. But that is
Monday at 900 p.m. Eastern, 8:00 p.m.
Central, 700 p.m. Mountain, and 6:00
p.m. Pacific time. And Albert is going
to tell us what time that is in South
Africa as he is our gatekeeper helping
to uh let people in. And also, if you're
calling in the middle of the night, then
he's the one that's supposed to be
answering because I like my beauty
sleep. Albert, what time would it would
900 p.m. Eastern be your time zone?
>> 3:00 a.m. in the morning.
>> What a.m.
>> 3:00 a.m. in the morning. Well, I'm up
at 4:30, so nope.
Still not going to be up at that time.
But thank you so much, Albert, for being
our um our
our night owl who's in actually your
daytime. We appreciate you so much. And
we have Coach Rod who is out on the
different platforms putting in comments,
questions, bringing in questions as
well. Thank you so much, Coach Rod, for
being here with us. And folks, thank you
for taking the time investing this hour
plus into your own health and wellness.
Share it with somebody you know, someone
you love. If you got somebody with skin
issues, you want to share it. You got
somebody that's taking a bunch of
pharmaceuticals and they're afraid to
take neutrauticals because there might
be an interaction. Well, their body's
nutrient deficient, not chemical
deficient. Share this program with them.
And if you've got an immunity issue,
share this program with them and remind
them to plug in or recommend that they
plug in for Monday's show. Thank you so
much again. Hope you're having a
fantastic weekend or had a great week. I
am going to have a fantastic weekend and
enjoy my last Friday at the age of 54.
So folks, have a great one. We'll talk
to you later. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.